January 6th is remembered as a day where
political violence rattled American
democracy as we saw our nation's leaders
like then house Speaker Nancy Pelosi
Sheltering in a safe house making calls
and in a now Infamous moment eating a
slim jim but the need for government
Refuge is nothing new during the peak of
the Cold War there was a secret bunker
for the entire U.S Congress Scott
McFarland traveled to the mountain state
for a rare look inside the
well-preserved facility and found
something powerful outside as well
hidden in the West Virginia mountains on
an 11 000 acre estate The Greenbrier
resort is an imposing white structure
but inside is draped in bright colors
and classical pieces a design originally
from the 1940s that's intentionally bold
there's no beige there's no beige around
here you know retired Greenbrier
historian Dr Robert Conti says it was an
escape for the most powerful how many
U.S presidents have been here 28 is a
current count as far back as Martin Van
Buren James Monroe was here but he was
only secretary of state at that point
and for 30 years The Greenbrier also had
a secret
Congress ordered construction of a
backup U.S Capitol that would double as
a nuclear fallout shelter below the
resort
we kind of forget how intense the Cold
War was the United States and the Soviet
Union and people at the time
particularly military people weren't
thinking if this is going to be used
they were thinking when it's going to be
used they would convene right here right
it wasn't just Hunker in the bunker they
were going to continue to function as
the legislative branch completed in
early 1962 it includes an auditorium as
the house chamber and bunk beds for all
535 members of congress the people who
operated the bunker had a mantra they
repeated over and over we were maintain
this at a constant state of operational
Readiness at a moment's notice at a
moment's notice with an infirmary police
equipment and a kitchen and dining room
these are the original floors yeah these
original floors and it was actually
designed this way to be sort of annoying
and irritating all these little little
black and white floorings that didn't
want people to sit around here they had
to do multiple sittings so eat and get
out was kind of their philosophy then
Congressional leaders Lyndon Johnson and
Sam Rayburn approved the plan
considering the location strategic if
war broke out they assumed the
Washington DC would be a primary target
why didn't they put the set of military
facility it would have been a lot easier
but Sam Rayburn and Lyndon Johnson they
wanted to maintain the independence of
the legislative they weren't going to
put their facility on a military base
that reports to the Executive Branch the
construction work was unknown even to
the staff of the resort how are you
going to build 112 000 square foot
underground bunker without people
noticing well you build an addition to
the green bar on top of it and you say
oh we're just adding to the green brown
we're just expanding the green bar and
they were
it operated until 1992 when it was
Declassified but the hotel held prior
rolls the war isn't over yet during
World War II the government transformed
The Greenbrier into an Army hospital and
it also served as an internment camp for
diplomats from enemy Nations
for Generations the bunker and the
resort above it were this refuge in
waiting a theoretical safe place until
the day it was no longer theoretical
the death toll from flooding in West
Virginia is at least 20. a thousand year
flood ripped apart White Sulfur Springs
in 2016 submerging the homes of many of
the greenbriar's employees including the
home of Mackenzie Moya who worked in the
Greenbrier as a teenager alongside her
mother Moya was pregnant when she lost
her home seems like it just happened
yesterday but then sometimes it it still
seems unbelievable that it happened it
was just an unimaginable scene to see
the town that I had grown up in just an
absolute ruin buildings were flattened
there were cars everywhere trees down
houses missing my dad calling me I can't
see your house anymore I'm not sure
where your mom is he was on a roof at my
neighbor's house your house was lifted
off the ground it came up off the
foundation and floated about a football
field away into my neighbor's house
behind me moya's Mom managed to survive
the torrent the two men that were with
her about six hours held her with a rope
around her in the tree and she wasn't
physically able to get completely into
the tree so some of her body was still
in the flood waters as she was clinging
to the tree for her life so the creek
water comes all the way up to the bridge
it was remarkable there was water from
The High Ground over here as far as you
can see architect and local business
owner Tom Crabtree recalls the
devastation
how many people were lost in this
community there were 13 perished the
greenbrier's grounds were wrecked but
its Hotel remained intact Greenbrier
opened their doors to anybody that was
displaced by the flood and and it was a
remarkable thing the rebuilding of White
Sulfur Springs continues but has already
made the city stronger
initially people invested in this town
by donating funds for volunteers to
build homes all of the construction
materials were purchased locally all of
the restaurants were serving food to
hundreds of volunteers
momentum continued and Main Street White
Sulfur Springs today has no vacant
storefronts has no vacant space
encouraging its people to stay what kept
me here was the opportunity to raise my
daughter in the same place that I was
raised in and played Sports in and loved
living you hear about the beauty in West
Virginia of like the landscape but the
sense of community that it brought
really shows you the people in this area
saving a place that's long been
America's Safe House
for CBS Saturday morning Scott McFarland
White Sulfur Springs West Virginia
Safe House indeed pretty fascinating I
like the bunk beds I know the arguments
that Congress has over who's going to
take one off can we imagine that the
discussion over who's who's taking which
bunk bed who's on top the bottom I
didn't even think about that Jeff that's
an excellent point brilliant Point
naturally you make it
just leave it right there